joe biden declares victory is on the way
against coveted while taking credit for
a bunch of stuff he didn't actually do
the pentagon attacks tucker carlson and
amazon says it will not allow books that
contradicts the lgbtq plus agenda i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
thousands of my listeners have already
secured their internet join them
at expressvpn.com ben will get to all
the news in just
one moment including president house
plant's big speech last night
on covet first let me remind you you are
spending way too much on that cell phone
bill the word is now out people are
abandoning
their overpriced wireless carriers
they're flocking to pure talk for the
same coverage but at a fraction of the
price that is correct
if you're with amazon or verizon at tt
mobile switching to puretalk could save
your family over 800
a year switching is really easy you can
keep your phone keep your number or get
huge discounts on the latest iphones and
androids and right now
you can get unlimited talk tech six gigs
of data for just 30 bucks a month
and if you go over on data they're not
going to charge you for it there's a
reason pure talk is the highest rated
wireless company by consumer affairs
stop giving your money to those
overpriced wireless carriers start
saving money today here's the thing a
lot of these wireless carriers they'll
trick you they'll tell you that what you
actually need is unlimited data but
you're not using unlimited data you're
not using anything close to unlimited
data
why not instead get unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data for 30 bucks a
month and if you go over
they're not going to charge you extra
for it anyway from your cell phones i'll
pound 250 say ben
shapiro you will save fifty percent off
your very first month that is pound two
five zero
say ben shapiro pure talk is simply
smarter wireless
again i'll pound 250 say ben shapiro
save 50
off your very first month alrighty so
last night
was joe biden's victory lap it was very
slow he had to take a few breathers
had to lie down a little bit you know
maybe hit the toilet for a metamucil
break
but joe eventually made it yesterday he
signed
this enormous 1.9 trillion dollar bill
right
now remember earlier this week when the
washington post was saying
every moment that this bill is delayed
people are dying so they delayed for
like 24 hours so you could sign the bill
then of course he signed the bill and
then he left without answering questions
because
president house plant must be protected
at all costs he's hiding the water stain
guys
if ever you move the house plant we're
all going to see the water stain so
yesterday president house plant signs
the the bill
and then it just leaves because that's
what he does now
thank you for being here where am i
though where is here
i got it thank you all appreciate it
up and out catch you later he's going to
stroll right on out
because that is the way things are done
here at the biden white house okay so
last night he does this big prime time
speech his first prime time address is
president of the united states he still
is not on a press conference where a
hundred
all right something uh 50 days in is he
this is the longest stretch that we have
gone without a presidential press
conference
in modern american history i believe uh
for a person who just entered office
so he gave a big primetime address last
night and the media found it absolutely
inspiring because of course they're
gonna find anything the man does
inspiring
if he if he hotboxes them if he farts in
a car with them it is inspiring stuff
for the media so abc and i just have to
show you how abc trotted this thing out
because it is indicative of how the news
media treat joe biden
so whenever trump did a speech would be
controversial embattled president donald
trump
gives a speech from the oval office will
he be able to pull out of his tailspin
that's the framing
now it's joe biden is here to save us
all the empath
in chief is here to cry with us and to
give us giant
lump sums of cash i mean my god what a
magnificent magnificent old man
here is abc news's lead up to joe
biden's incredible
speech last night this is in abc news
special report the pandemic one year
later
where does america go from here a new
chapter
vaccinations ramping up more than 64
million americans now with at least
one dose of the vaccine and a promise of
a big enough vaccine supply for
all adults in this country by the end of
may the historic
new coveted relief bill now signed into
law
there is light at the end of this dark
tunnel in the past year
how soon will help arrive and as a
country honors
more than 528 thousand lives lost
we must also ask about our future and
how soon before america can find
some form of normalcy tonight in prime
time
president biden addresses the nation i
mean
that's unbelievable that's cut directly
by the dnc right except it's abc wrong
initials
that is your news media joe biden
bringing us hope
when will we return to normalcy a
historic relief bill
shove it man okay so anyway joe biden
finally gives this speech
and um the speech is not good the speech
is filled with untruths
he continues to maintain the fiction
that kovid is going to burst out at any
second and eat your face
that kovid is gonna rise in any moment
and that he must maintain control
and also that apparently he created the
vaccine he created the vaccine roll out
and he ended covet
amazing for a man who has been asleep
for the last several years
he's the rip van winkle of covid he went
to sleep when he woke up covered was
over
but now he thinks that it's actually his
his victory he's the one who did it
so he leaves off by talking about how
the virus
led off and what he says is not true
okay the virus was already spreading by
february this we know
in the united states it was spreading by
february this dude was doing rallies as
of march 10th
of last year okay currently today it is
march 12th
so he's like well you know a year ago we
met and people were just dismissing the
virus
yeah literally a year ago you were doing
rallies man okay
here's joe biden pretending that all of
his predecessors particularly trump
ignored the virus even though i seem to
remember everybody being locked in their
home last year around this time
a year ago were hit with a virus
that was met with silence and spread
unchecked
denials for days weeks then months
that led to more deaths more infections
more stress and more loneliness weird
because um you know one of the people
you guys were championing was andrew
cuomo
the number two guy in terms of death per
million also phil murphy number one guy
in terms of deaths per million
so what exactly is your suggestion joe
biden
considering that it was people like
doctor anthony foundry telling people
not to mask up
and that the major metros of the united
states actually did lock down
none of this happens to be accurate then
he gets to his point we're only going to
we're only going to get back to our
lives by defeating the virus
again you didn't do anything dude the
parade was moving and then they wheeled
you out in front of it
and then you claimed that you are
leading the parade that's not how any of
this works
you're just harrison ford in the
fugitive infiltrating the parade and
putting on a green hat and pretending
you're there for st patrick's day that's
not what this
is okay the parade was already moving
you moving out in front of it and then
claiming they like
he's i'm sorry this is ridiculous
serious
and for all of you asking when things
will get back to normal
here is the truth the only way to get
our lives back
to get our economy back on track is to
beat the virus you've been hearing me
say that for while i was running and the
last
50 days i've been president but this is
one of the most
complex operations we've under ever
undertaken as a nation in a long time
okay um he is not coherent he's not
saying things that
are true and when he is saying things
that are true they're complete
platitudes the only way to get back to
normal is to defeat the virus who would
have thought guys who would have thought
that the only way to get back to normal
is when the virus starts to wane
unique thoughts from joe biden by the
way even that is not wholly true okay
the virus
was still around last summer states like
florida
opened up people were allowed to make
their own decisions and you know what
happened
florida outperformed all of joe biden's
favorite states hey then joe biden
starts taking credit for stuff and this
part is the most ridiculous thing okay
by the time he took office we were
already giving a million shots a day we
were already on pace
to give 100 million shots in a hundred
days because we were already giving a
million shots per day by the time the
guy took office
okay and now he's taking credit for the
elderly getting their shots remember by
the end of february he was supposed to
have set up 100 federal sites all around
the country for mass vaccination
the actual number of sites set up by joe
biden according to the associated press
seven so no you don't get to take credit
for the elderly getting their shots
you know who gets to take credit for
that the various governors who've
actually made sure that the elderly get
their shots
you know he can tell because there are
certain areas where they've done a
crappy job making sure the elderly can
get their shots
because they've been instead tranching
out the vaccines based on equity
meaning based on race as opposed to
based on age which makes no sense
at all but here is joe biden taking
credit for stuff that he's not
responsible for as he has pretty much
his entire career remember the only
reason he's president is because he was
barack obama's vice president he's not
responsible
for anything that he has done over the
course of the last several months
he was the default against bernie
sanders because basically everybody said
i'd rather vote for the corps
than vote for the socialist and then he
was the default against trump because
they said i'd rather vote for the corpse
than vote
for orange man bad and then he takes
advantage of a vaccine program not
created by him
and a distribution program not headed by
him and then says that he is the guy who
made all of it happen which is just not
true and the media of course are just
they're just sycophantically drooling
over the guy which is unbelievable
because again
he is a house plant okay i understand
that you like the house plant
i understand that geraniums are nice but
guess what
the president being a house plant does
not make him a leader you can't
simultaneously be a leader in house plan
here's president house plan taking
credit for things
when i took office 50 days ago
only eight percent of the americans
after months
only eight percent of those over the age
of 65 have gotten their first
vaccination
today that number is 65 percent
just 14 percent of americans
over the age of 75 50 50 days ago had
gotten their first shot
today that number is well over 70
percent
okay so a couple things one he's citing
the increase in the percentages
they were already ramping up you can see
the line okay you can see the line
if you look at the actual line as to the
percentages of people who are getting
the vaccine
what you'll see is does not look
exponential it does not look like it was
a low rate
and then biden came in and magically
fixed the program and then all of a
sudden it started to skyrocket that's
not what it looks like it looks like a
consistent arithmetic increase
okay that's what it looks like but here
he is saying that he is responsible
solely
for the increase in the number of the
elderly vaccinated his own cdc
was recommending standards that did not
actually comply with the idea that we
were going to do it based on age
states that actually transferred it out
to the elderly were doing it in spite of
biden they were doing it in spite of the
cdc
we read you the cdc standards the cdc
standards took into account equity
they suggested that frontline workers
who are 20 because they were
disproportionately minority
ought to be given the vaccine alongside
75 year olds who made no sense at all
it was only under pressure the cdc even
walked that back
so the way that this works is that joe
biden is going to take credit for
everything ron desantis did well
and then he's going to yell at ron
desantis for being a bad governor that's
the way all of this works basically
he is not responsible for any of this he
has not overseen
a damned thing okay it has been states
that have overseen this stuff he had one
job
his one job was to obtain the vaccine
any president worth his salt would have
done so he has now obtained some for
some odd reason four times the amount of
vaccine that the united states actually
needs
and now he's claiming credit for a
vaccine distribution program that he
does not had
it is all headed locally and state-based
okay now biden makes a big announcement
so you saw it in that abc news
that abc news sexual favor to joe biden
where he said wow he's gonna he
announces that everyone will be eligible
to get this
the shot by may 1st i'm going to order
it okay buddy
let's just be straight about this
everybody is going to be getting the
shot
by may 1st without you without you
all the adults are going to be getting
the shots having nothing to do with your
silly edict you know who promised that
we would actually all have the shots by
the beginning of june and y'all mocked
him
president trump now it's been
accelerated by one month
because governors have done a better job
than you did by the way
and now you're saying oh well look at me
i i've never seen somebody so
it really is it's amazing he is eager to
just get out in front
of parades that he did not create and
that are not for him
it's it's bizarro world here he was
saying adults are going to be able to
get the shots by may 1st and the media
treating this is transformative
the folks over the new york times is
amazing what what an amazing promise
all the adults are going to be able to
get the vaccine okay adults are
already getting the vaccines adults are
already getting the vaccines that has
nothing to do with his magical edicts
here he is the houseplant
tonight i'm announcing that i will
direct all states
tribes and territories to make all
adults
people 18 and over eligible to be
vaccinated
no later than may 1. let me say that
again
all adult americans will be eligible to
get a vaccine
no later than may 1.
that's much earlier than expected no it
isn't
it's not it's what was expected if you
just watch the trajectory again he's
just saying like
the sun will rot the sun is gonna rise
in the
minute in the in the morning in the east
i declare an edict that it will be so
and he falls over everybody's like whoa
that's amazing
you know the sun wasn't going to rise in
the east until joe biden said it now
that your biden said the sun's gonna
rise in the east
amazing if it weren't for joe biden the
sun would not have risen we'd all be
dead
we would all be dead but joe biden
declared the sun will rise in the east
and set in the west and unbelievably
enough that's actually what's going to
happen
what an amazing guy joe biden is it's
like that it's like connecticut yanking
king arthur's court right
he knows that there's going to be a
solar eclipse and so he predicts the
solar eclipse because he's from the
future right he knows when the solar
eclipse is going to happen
she's a magic man we all know except
except it's not a miracle we all know
that the trajectory is to this point in
fact
joe biden is so ridiculous that he is
now reversing trajectory
on things like school reopenings so in
some things he's like
yeah it looks like they're gonna be
enough shots trenched out for people to
get it by may first and i'll take credit
for that
on other things he is actively moving
against
best medical and scientific advice so
here he was last night saying we're
accelerating plans to open schools what
the f do you mean accelerating plans to
open schools my kids
have both been in school since september
the hell are you talking about
most kids in the united states are
attending some form of school in person
your cdc recommended that 99 of kids be
in hybrid learning
or at home only situations
you're accelerating plans to open the
schools you've been one of the lead
factors
in in stymieing plans to open schools
you've been one of the lead obstacles
they put the house plant in front of the
train here is joe biden saying he's
accelerating plans to open schools again
this is it's just nonsense and
what is maddening about this is the gas
lighting the media declaring that this
is transformative stuff
he just used kovid as an excuse to cram
down
a two trillion dollar boondoggle
designed to pay off all of his political
allies at the state and local levels
and to pay off the unions and to set up
these massive entitlement programs that
he intends to keep around
far beyond the lifespan of covet that's
all this was
and now he's declaring victory amazing a
week ago was in victory today it's
victory
here he says we're accelerating plans to
open schools accelerating plans
his entire administration has been run
by the teachers unions top to bottom
ridiculous crap with the passage of the
american rescue plan
and i thank again the house and senate
for passing it
and my announcement last month of a plan
to vaccinate teachers
and school staff including bus drivers
we can accelerate massive nationwide
effort to reopen
our schools safely and meet my goal
that i stated at the same time about 100
million shots
of opening majority of k-8 schools
in my first hundred days in office a
majority of k-8 schools are already open
they're already open he's just again
i declare that my goal is that tomorrow
morning
the sky will exist not even that it'll
be blue that it will exist and media's
like oh my god he made the sky
exist that's unbelievable oh it's so
maddening it's so maddening because if
you follow politics on a day-to-day
basis
you know that what he's saying is untrue
you know that him claiming credit for
stuff that is not his responsibilities
untrue and
that he has reversed progress in things
like school reopenings
it's absurd but again the media have a
stake in
endless democratic rule and so they will
continue to pump this guy up they'll
continue
to prop up bernie and wheel him around
as though that guy's leading the parade
okay in just a second we'll get to some
more of his ridiculous pronouncements in
this speech which again
was treated as a hopeful speech by the
media i didn't hear a lot of hope here
what i heard is a guy who wants to
maintain control
because control allows him to do all the
things he wants to do we'll get to more
of this in one second first
let us talk about the fact that there
are easy ways to upgrade the look and
feel of your home one of those ways is
your window coverings blinds.com they
make it simple to shop top quality
blinds shades and interior shutters from
home
with easy online ordering and free
shipping the experts at blinds.com
understand that window treatments are
one of the household items you don't
just think about but
they can in fact make an enormous impact
on the look and feel of your home
if you've ever walked into a home where
they just have like the old fashioned
blinds from the wire
they look they look terrible right and
then you walk into a home and they've
got
brand new shades or brand new shutters
and they look great well you can upgrade
and you can do it quickly and easily go
to blinds.com just take a look at all
the options
you got faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades even outdoor shades if
you're nervous about trying them there's
no reason to be because blinds.com has
helped
millions of homeowners through the
process plus they guarantee the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or have
them measure and install everything
for you i really appreciate the fact
that we have great window coverings in
our home i want everybody to have the
same head on over to blinds.com see how
much you can save when you check out
online don't forget to tell them you
heard about blinds.com from the ben
shapiro show helps us
helps them rules and restrictions that
may apply again check them out at
blinds.com right now and when you check
out remember to let them know they
heard about them here on the ben shapiro
show okay so
then joe biden says you should listen to
anthony fauci about the vaccines
here is the thing anthony fauci keeps
saying things that are scientifically
untrue about the vaccines
he's been saying for weeks that because
he doesn't know
he has no idea whether if you get the
vaccine you can pass this along
you should really only get together in
small groups you shouldn't get on an
airplane all this is crap it's not true
okay there are studies out from pfizer
they demonstrate that transmission rates
are
90 percent down for people who have the
vaccine that the effect
the effectiveness rate in terms of
preventing serious illness is something
like 97 percent
and the effectiveness rate in preventing
death is like 99 percent
as dr marti makari of johns hopkins
university has said once you have the
vaccines and once it has taken meaning
the first month one month after you take
that first vaccine you should be able to
go out take off the mask
and live your life you are now protected
that's not what fouch is saying
fouchy is continued with this line
pushed out by the biden administration
that we have to be cautious now why do
the democrats want to be cautious
because the more cautious you are the
more the economy suffers and the more
the economy suffers the more they can
blow out the spending
with everybody clamoring for more money
the reason that this bill is popular is
because people still perceive that covet
is a crisis and they believe that this
is just a one-time giveaway
it ain't a one-time giveaway it it
increases
structural problems inside state and
local governments that have not been
forced to look again at their budgets
it generates child tax credits to people
who
don't even pay taxes without regard for
family structure it does not incentivize
work it does not intensify family
formation
okay these are these are programs that
are meant to be permanent democrats are
openly saying this now
hey but here is joe biden saying listen
to fouchy listen to the science captain
we need to keep the schools closed here
listen to anthony fauci who by the way
should have been fired long ago
we've got work to do to ensure that
everyone has confidence in
the safety and effectiveness of all
three vaccines
so my message to you is this listen to
dr fauci
one of the most distinguished and
trusted voices in the world
he's assured us the vaccines are safe
they underwent rigorous scientific
review
i know they're safe vice president haron
harris and i know they're safe he's not
even speaking english
honest to god he is not speaking english
anymore okay and then
he continued it's amazing and we we had
a we had full-on debates last year
between two people who couldn't speak
english
and they say that this isn't the diverse
country in any case joe biden says that
by july 4th
we can get back to our traditional
celebrations now this is what i needed i
needed permission
from this old coot telling me what i can
and cannot do i've needed permission
from my politicians all the way along
because you see i'm not a sentient human
being with the ability to assess risk
i'm not a person who looks at risks and
then makes my own assessment even though
that's exactly what i like all other
human beings do
now i'm the kind of person where when i
saw that the virus was spreading widely
last year
it was around purim time in the jewish
community before any of the lockdowns
went into effect i told my parents we're
not going to pour in parties because i
can see this is a problem
i was an advocate of masking when there
was widespread in the community
i was never an advocate of mandatory
mask programs because i didn't think
they were effective and they wouldn't be
enforceable but
i was an advocate of masking i was
always one of the more cautious people i
knew
about covid and yet the idea is that i'm
not allowed to make my own assessment
i need joe biden to make an assessment
for me okay so now he lays out something
that is completely a scientific
the standard that joe biden is about to
lay out right here is completely
anti-scientific it is not the science it
is not what his own cd standards cdc
standards recommend
once again he is downplaying
expectations knowing that we're going to
meet those expectations long before
the date that he's setting and so one of
the problems for president trump in
politics is that he kept over-promising
and then under
delivering which was weird because he
had a lot to deliver right he would say
we're going to have
97 economic growth and then we have like
five percent economic growth which is
really good
it'd be like he missed his mark joe
biden will be like
we're gonna have seven percent but
negative economic growth and it'll be
like a two percent growth rate be like
oh
that was amazing so that's what he's
doing with kelvin right now what he's
doing is he's saying you know at a
certain point in the long way future
maybe you can get together with small
groups and then guess what
you can get together with small groups
right now if you're vaccinated in fact
scientifically speaking you can get
together with large groups right now if
you're vaccinated but here's joe biden
telling you what you can and cannot do
because you need advice
from this old codger if we do all this
if we do our part if we do this together
by july the 4th there's a good chance
you
your families and friends will be able
to get together in your backyard or in
your neighborhood
and have a cookout at a barbecue and
celebrate independence day
that doesn't mean large events with lots
of people together but it does mean
small groups will be able to get
together after this long hard year
together according to joe biden
okay in a second i'm going to explain to
you why this is so unbelievably stupid
okay and anti-scientific according to
his own administration
we'll get to that in one second first
let us talk about the fact that a lot of
people have a balance on their credit
cards
and you got a higher interest rate than
you would prefer i mean the fact is one
of the ways that people get in serious
trouble is they rack up the charges on
the credit card and then they don't pay
it off and then all of a sudden you get
in charge
just insane percentages on your interest
rate and you get really behind the eight
ball it's a really bad way of falling
into
a serious financial situation instead
why not pay off your credit cards and
save with a credit card consolidation
loan from lightstream
rates start at just 5.95 april with
autopay and excellent credit
it's much lower than the national
average interest rate on credit cards
plus the rate is fixed so it's never
going to go up over the life of the loan
get a loan from 5 000 bucks to 100 000
bucks with absolutely no fees
you can even get your money as soon as
the day you apply lightstream believes
people with good credit deserve a better
loan experience and that is exactly
what they deliver again i've seen a lot
of people who have fallen into credit
card debt not something you want to do
instead
go consolidate those credit card loans
right now and save with a credit card
consolidation loan from lightstream just
for my listeners you can apply right now
to get a special interest rate discount
and save even more the only way to get
the discount go to lightstream.com
shapiro that's l-i-g-h-t s-t-r-e-a-m
dot com shapiro lightstream.com shapiro
subject credit approval rates range from
5.95
apr to 19.99 apr and includes 0.50
auto pay discount lowest rate requires
excellent credit terms and conditions
apply officers are subject to change
without notice visit lightstream.com
shapiro for more information okay so you
heard joe biden right there say
maybe by july 4th maybe by july 4th so
first of all it's fun that we get to
celebrate july 4th again
because for a while there it seemed like
july 4th was a celebration of the most
terrible country ever to be created and
colin kaepernick put out a whole post
about how july 4th was terrible
great patriot that colin kaepernick is
being celebrated by the democratic party
apparently july 4th is now back on the
menu so that's good
also he says by july 4th you can get
together with i love how he just trots
that out there's like
you can get together with your neighbors
and their family
and friends at a cookout not in big
groups
in small groups okay i'm going to read
to you from the cdc website you ready
fully vaccinated people can quote visit
with other fully vaccinated people
indoors without wearing masks or
physical distancing
visit with unvaccinated people from a
single household who are at low risk for
severe covet disease indoors without
wearing masks or physical distancing
refrain from quarantine and testing
following a known exposure
if asymptomatic in other words today
not july 4th today march 12th if you are
fully vaccinated you can get together
with small groups of people
according to the cdc and the cdc
guidelines are way the hell too
restrictive
because guess what that cdc standard
makes no sense i'm going to read that
last line again
they say that if you're fully vaccinated
you can refrain from quarantine and
testing
following a known exposure if you're
asymptomatic which means
they are not worried that you are going
to get it if you are if you are
vaccinated they are not worried that you
are going to spread it
if you are vaccinated which means if
you're vaccinated you should be able to
go out into whatever the hell you want
okay so the cdc is too restrictive and
then biden's like the cdc standard that
applies today
if we're good little boys and girls then
i will grant you the crumb of freedom
that on july 4th you'll be able to do
july 4th
the f are you talking about dude you're
not like three months down the road
march to april april to may may to june
june to july you're talking about four
months down the road
right now four months okay
we we actually already are meeting in
these groups
like a while ago nobody's paying
attention to him
and and people and my favorite part of
this entire speech is he this whole
thing about how
what we really learned is that we have
to trust government no that's pretty
much the last thing we learned here
the last thing we learned is that we
need to trust government what we
actually learned is that we need to
trust big pharma
that's what we actually learned here
because big pharma did the heavy lifting
government didn't develop crap
the government provided financial
incentives that were perfectly obvious
to everyone
okay but but the reality is that it was
it was individual decision making it was
state and localities that allowed people
to live their lives
it was big pharma developing a vaccine
in record time
those are the people who ought to
deserve credit if we're going to look at
big government
democrats and how they did during this
pandemic the answer is they did
unbelievably horribly
again the worst states in america were
the ones that locked down places like
new york and new jersey
california wrecked its economy locked
everyone in their house for a year
and have the same death permian rate as
florida which didn't lock anybody up
opened all of its schools and told
people to go live their lives
and by the way joe biden just wants to
let you know that while he is saying
that you might be able to get together
in small groups by july also he might
shut it down again
there might have to be more shutdowns
nope nope the data demonstrates the
shutdowns have not been useful the
lockdowns have not been useful
but here's joe biden threatening you
again if you're not good little girls
and boys
and non-gender binary
humans then i guess that you know maybe
if you're
if you're bad if you don't listen to joe
biden then he might lock you down again
old man might lock in the closet again
unity is what we do together as fellow
americans because we don't stay vigilant
and the conditions change then we may
have to reinstate restrictions
to get back on track and please we don't
want to do that again
we've made so much progress this is not
the time to let up
what do you mean not the time to let up
like we're getting vaccines
what are you talking about right now
okay so this all plays into the broader
democratic narrative which is that joe
biden is curing kovid
by spending oodles of money we don't
need to spend because the reality again
is that covet is on the way we're at the
lowest infection rates since the
beginning of the pandemic
people are getting out and about they're
going back to their regular lives after
they are vaccinated
they are meeting with their families
they are going out to parties they are
doing all the normal things
that they ought to do they ought to take
off the masks it is good for american
society that we can see each other's
faces it is good to relieve the
depression
and anxiety that come along with
isolation if we can go back to leading
our regular lives but democrats don't
want that because then they wouldn't
have the impetus to spend
more money again and again and again so
chuck schumer makes the absurd
contention that we're going to be back
to normal because of the covered relief
bill that's absurd
we're going to be back to normal because
we can all go back to work and we go to
parties and we go to concerts and we go
to baseball games
we're not going to be back to normal
because you sent a bunch of checks to
people who weren't unemployed in the
first place
here's chuck schumer saying just stupid
crap
the fourteen hundred dollars matters
help is on the way the vaccines
they're going to come much quicker and
much more widespread
than people ever thought it is now
thought that maybe even as early as june
we'll have enough people vaccinated that
we can go back to life as normal who
wouldn't want that
so this bill it has so many good things
so many good things
and it's geared to what america needs no
it is absolutely not geared to what
america needs it's geared to where
democrats need
it spends hundreds of billions of
dollars on states and localities that
have run their businesses like crap and
they are finding essentially states that
have stayed open
in favor of states that have stayed
closed the the bill is a monstrosity
it's a terrible bill it's a really
really bad bill
okay meanwhile i got zeke emanuel who i
it is
kind of weird that one of the chief
advisors to the president of the united
states on covet 19
is a person who wrote a column not all
that long ago saying that he wanted to
die at the age of 75.
covet kills people over the age of 75.
so
all right but apparently he says that by
summer or early fall
we'll be back to normal summer or early
fall how about next week
next week sound good for you how about
last week how about like
months ago people were back to living
their lives they were just socially
distancing
and wearing masks and how about the fact
that once they have the vaccines as in
like now particularly the people who are
most vulnerable because if you're 20 you
ain't dying to covet by the statistics
your chances of dying are
extraordinarily low by the stats
okay how about once all the people who
are most vulnerable that have been
vaccinated we go back to our regular
lives but no we have to have the experts
tell us
you need the guidance of a man who said
he would like to die at 75 about the
deadliness of a disease that kills
people mainly over the age of 75. here's
ezekiel emanuel
we don't know exactly where he herd
immunity and
sort of killing the spread happens
but somewhere in that time so it does
look like summer
early fall we will be getting back to
normal um and it's really important i
think katie you know what
normal isn't covid goes away entirely
normal is
um you know the background risk of covid
goes to something like the background
risk
of flu uh and it just becomes part of
the
everyday life oh well i guess that
i guess that if he says so then i guess
we'll all just lock up until you know
late summer or early fall or we won't do
any of that
because these people are not in charge
nor should they be in charge but again
they have to give you the impression
that they did it that the experts did it
the government experts the public health
experts not
the actual experts who created the
vaccine not the governors who let you
live your life
no the people who who made all this
magic happen are the people who are in
top down control why do they need that
impression
because if they ever give up that
impression we might say well then why do
you need to spend
all this taxpayer money why do we need
to trust you to reset all of america's
social and economic standards
but there's great enthusiasm for that at
this moment and it crosses the aisle
and people like david brooks it's
amazing does the new york times have a
single conservative columnist at this
point
ross duthat is the only one who could
maybe be considered a conservative
ross is ross is the most conservative of
them but david brooks is not a
conservative anymore i mean david brooks
just came out in favor of joe biden's
entire economic plan
he said there was a premise throughout
american history that if you worked hard
you would earn economic security that's
not as true for millennials in
generation z or many other people across
america
what is he talking about we had the
highest employment rate
in modern american history one year ago
one year ago he says well you know we
have a different emotional climate that
the pandemic has magnified a climate of
insecurity and precarity
these realities have produced an
intellectual revolution it was assumed
even only a decade ago the fed could not
just print money with abandon
it was assumed the government could not
rack up huge debt without spurring
inflation
and crippling debt payment costs both of
these concerns have been thrown out the
window
by large numbers of thinkers well i mean
if the thinkers say so we've seen years
of high debt and loose monetary policy
but inflation
has not come i mean it has not come
because
the demand did not show up in mass
number so you didn't get the price
inflation okay and because all the other
countries around the world were doing
the same thing that we were
which meant that we were still a good
bet when it came to the dollar but if we
decided to blow this thing out
in unilateral fashion no people are not
going to buy our debt
but says david brooks the restraints
have been cast aside we are now
experiencing monetary and fiscal
policies that would have been
unimaginable a decade ago the role of
government is being redefined
this isn't socialism this is not the
federal government taking control of the
commanding heights of the economy
this is not a bunch of programs to
restrain corporate power americans
trusting government is still low
this is the transfer state government
redistributing massive amounts of money
by cutting checks to people and having
faith that they spend it
in the right ways both parties are
adjusting to the new paradigm
and he says i'm worried about a world in
which we spend borrowed money with
abandon
but income inequality widespread child
poverty and economic property are the
problems of our time
it's worth taking a risk to tackle all
of this i i love this kind of economic
thinking
sure all the wisdom in the past doesn't
apply anymore because bad things are
happening
so it's worth risking the entire
american economy which one year ago was
booming under completely the reverse
of of joe biden's policies it's worth
risking the
fundamental basis of that economy in
order to
what fight problems that that were
already on the wane by the time the
pandemic hit
we had the fastest wage growth in
decades under trump
and david brooks is like well that was a
crisis by the way how
how ridiculous are the democrats
assessments of the economy at this point
they're so ridiculous
that the washington post editorial board
is going guys slow up on the spending
the washington post the washington post
has an editorial today
saying there are two assertions we can
confidently make about the level of
federal debt the us can sustain
first it is higher than many
commentators ourselves included commonly
supposed until recently
second it is not infinite congress needs
to take both of these points into
account
as it considers what to do now that
president biden's 1.9 trillion dollar
coveted relief package has passed with a
proposal for another
2 trillion or more in infrastructure
spending on the way
the right answer isn't submitted to
pivot to deficit reduction
of course we had reservations about the
size of the newly approved bill
the 350 billion dollars allocated to
state local and tribal governments
seems excessive given their strong
recent tax revenue recovery
nevertheless there's a case for
borrowing a lot of money but let's be
real we need
higher revenues reduce spending on lower
priority items a mix of the two
they say that debt that is large and
uncontrolled would be unprecedented in
american history
and according to the cbl risky so even
the washington post is starting to get
nervous about the kind of spending that
biden is proposing
but don't worry they'll come around
because they're the washington post and
the media will prop up by
again i keep saying it over and over but
president house plan is necessary for
the democrats because he is an
unthreatening face on a very threatening
policy
his threatening policy of top-down
coveted control
his threatening policy of we're going to
spend more money than has ever yet been
created
his threatening policy of we're going to
take over every institution
of the american government and outside
the american government in favor of
equity-based
wokeness is deeply dangerous to american
society they just have to slap
this old stir's face on it because he
has an unthreatening face
right that's all this is about it's all
it always was about by the way how
threatening
is this administration getting according
to axios.com
president biden is now being encouraged
to effectively pack the nation's top
campaign finance regulator with
officials who more doggedly enforce laws
regulating political money
the fec has been gridlocked for years
now
some are pushing biden to abandon
protocol by sidestepping congressional
republicans
and nominating regulators will more
aggressively enforce campaign finance
rules
they want to just get rid of the of the
republicans on the commission
by law the six-member fec can have no
more than three commissioners from
either major political party but there
is one independent
right now and one of the two new
republican commissioner sean cooksey was
confirmed in december
biden could nominate a true democrat to
replace cooksey giving the commission a
four-member pro-enforcement majority
this of course would completely
undermine the ability of republicans to
fight back understand that campaign
finance reform
is a direct response by democrats to the
threat of new media
okay the old media is a giant in-kind
contribution to the democratic party
new media and super pacs and people
spending corporate money in order to
elect republicans that is a direct
response to the fact that the
the corporate media is designed on
behalf of democrats and operates on
behalf of democrats at this point so if
you can stack the fec
so that everybody gets regulated except
for the labor unions and big media
you know what the outcome is going to be
and that is what biden is being
encouraged to do at this point alrighty
coming up
we're going to get to the pentagon
attacking tucker carlson which
you know it's weird i seem to remember
people suggesting it was fascist for
members of the government to attack the
press
now you have the pentagon literally
commenting on fox news shows
and um not to deny reports but just to
rip on a commentator
and this is considered okay i'm weird
weird
now here's the thing i truly believe the
world would be a better place if people
spent a lot more time reading books okay
and that is why
they need to pick up a copy of andrew
clavin's
next book it's the next installment of
another kingdom
another kingdom is a terrific kind of
fantasy noir series
he just released the third and final
installment in his another kingdom
series the emperor sword finds austin
lively on the run between two realities
as his enemies close in on all sides
despite wild success in life he begins
to realize a recurring vision is
actually a nightmare in disguise
he's caught in the coils of a terrible
magic the only way he can save the soul
give up his success re-enter the elven
lands and find the emperor anastasia so
he can restore queen olinda to her
throne if you haven't read the few books
you have no idea what i'm talking about
but this is why you should read the
first two books and then
pick up the emperor's sword it is now
available for purchase online go to
amazon.com search
the emperor's sword also big news last
november we announced
candace owens would be joining the daily
wire family people have been asking
for months when is candice's show
starting when's it starting i've gotten
so many questions about this
here's your answer next friday march
19th but
you must be a subscriber in order to see
candace's new show you have to be a
member
no one triggers the left quite like
candace obviously she trends every
couple of days whether she's slamming
harry styles or wearing a dress
or getting into twitter wars with cardi
b for her shakespearean lyrics
many have tried to cancel all have
failed if you don't know candace
you should until in 2018 she kicked off
the blexit foundation it aims to change
the narrative surrounding america's
minority communities she's also the
author of the new york times bestseller
blackout how black america can make its
second
escape from the democrat plantation get
to know candice the real candice every
week she's going to share her humor her
insight
and she defies all the stereotypes
starting next friday march 19th that's
next friday
candace will be exclusive to daily wire
members if you aren't a member yet
you need to head on over right now to
dailywire.com subscribe use code
candice for 25 off your subscription
that's dailywire.com
subscribe use code canvas for 25 off
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
so remember that time when president
trump was a fascist dictator remember
that time
because he would criticize the press it
was like every time he said something
bad about jim acosta
the entire media was in a frenzy it's an
attack on our free
breath okay that's just terrible he's a
bad man he's a bad orange man
what if i told you that the pentagon is
full on attacking a journalist
like full on attacking a journalist so
tucker carlson did a segment the other
night
on joe biden making a speech about how
we were creating new military uniforms
for
pregnant mothers or some such and tucker
made a suggestion which was you know
typically pregnant mothers are not going
to be
on duty so that's a very weird thing to
trot out as sort of your
top of line as sort of your top line
change to the military in a time where
our military really requires building up
in the face of a chinese threat it seems
weird to lead with
also we created a uniform for pregnant
ladies
or pregnant people because sorry forgive
me some men can get pregnant
so tucker said this and the world was
set aflame
how dare he say anything remotely like
this now let me make this absolutely
clear everybody who's serving in the
military and has volunteered for duty is
doing something i didn't and they are
braver than i
okay that is right up front also it is
kind of a weird thing to lead with
our military policy is we created
uniforms for pregnant women
because pregnant women aren't typically
going to be the ones who are doing the
fighting they're not going to be the
ones
who are flying the jets they're not
going to be the ones who are on the
front line combat teams
they're pregnant right seems fairly
obvious
but for tucker saying this he was taken
to task by the pentagon itself
because we are now in the business of
having government agencies respond
directly to journalists they don't like
and owning them because the pentagon i
kid you not put out an actual headline
yesterday
about owning the cons they put out a
headline like the pentagon destroys
tucker carlson which is a different
headline than the pentagon destroys a
terrorist with a drone
but i mean kind of weird okay so
according to axios the pentagon
condemned
tucker carlson for mocking women in the
military during the segment
carlson said that president biden's
acknowledgment that policies are
changing to encourage more women to join
and stay in the armed forces was a
mockery
of the united states military well
that's not exactly what he said but
kirby who is the who is the pentagon
press secretary
he called out tucker carlson he said i
want to be clear right up front the
diversity of our military is one of our
greatest
strengths well no
i mean that's that's not true the
strength of our military is one of our
greatest strengths
having a lot of people who can meet like
basic fitness standards that is a great
strength
having a lot of people great at their
jobs that's a great strength diversity
in its purest term
is obviously not one of the great
strengths of the military not meaning
that it's like a bad thing to have a
bunch of people who are racially diverse
in the military
that's fine that's wonderful but if
you're talking about the chief strengths
of the american military and you're
talking about diversity you don't have a
lot of fat people in the military you
shouldn't have a lot of fat people in
the military because you need them to
actually do things
right you shouldn't have a bunch of
people who have congenital heart disease
in the military
there are actual standards to get into
the military and those those
standards to get in the military are
good because what we are actually
interested in creating in this effect is
ineffective
fighting force so if you are looking for
criteria on how to
to how to judge the quality of a
military diversity ranks fairly low on
the list
it's like effectiveness physical fitness
ability under fire and then like
the racial makeup of the military that
one
is kind of irrelevant like
that's like it it's nice but it's not
relevant to the
to the actual fighting fitness of a
fighting force obviously
okay but the idea that diversity is like
the number one priority of the military
which is sort of what biden and pentagon
are now saying is very bizarre
and the the military is generally not
supposed to be the place
for social engineering it's supposed to
be the place where you kick the hell out
of people who try to attack us that's
what the military is
is generally for we have lots of places
for social engineering in american
society
the military is not the number one place
for that now the military has been used
in the past for some pretty excellent
social engineering namely the
desegregation of the military by harry
truman right that was a very very good
thing and i'm glad that harry truman did
it
but the notion that that is the purpose
of the military as opposed to an attempt
to broaden the scope of the military to
encompass more people who are qualified
at a basic level to do the job
that is a different thing okay so kirby
says quote i want to be very clear
upfront the diversity of our military is
one of our greatest
strengths i've seen it for myself in
long months at sea and in combat waged
by our troops in afghanistan and iraq
i've seen it up on capitol hill just
this past month i see it every day right
here at the pentagon what we absolutely
won't do is take personnel advice from a
talk show host or the chinese military
maybe those folks feel like they have
something to prove that's on them
then the us army responded on twitter
with a series of photos of female troops
along the phrase
i am an american soldier so we now have
the pentagon in a direct like flame war
with tucker carlson
way to way to go after america's enemies
guys
really well done imagine if the pentagon
had done this under
president trump imagine if you know
jonathan chait
had said something about why the
military's transgender policy is super
bad and the pentagon had just put out a
bunch of memes
attacking jonathan chait you'd be like
why is the administration doing that
why is the executive branch attacking
journalists this way but apparently it's
totally fine to do it so long as it's
tucker carlson and it's in favor of
of the woke ideology that diversity is
like the chief priority of the military
okay so this sort of stuff unfortunately
uh is becoming more and more common
obviously not just from the government
but also socially speaking there's an
attempt to bully out of public existence
anybody who happens to be on the right
this is why you have msnbc's nicole
wallace now saying that any single
company that donates to the gop
is a racist company she of course says
the century reads bizarre show
the republicans are now openly trying to
disenfranchise voters
they're acknowledging that the more
people vote
the worse the margins for republicans
will be and any company that thinks they
can give money to republicans because
maybe they like their positions on
regulations or taxes
needs to understand that they're voting
for voter suppression and if it's a
company that has a product
they need to i think understand that
that product will be associated
with racist disenfranchisement of black
voters so the uh
here's nicole wallace openly calling on
people to boycott any company that
associates with
her political opponents pretty amazing
stuff
but that is the world in which we now
live i top down government control
pushed by joe biden and
and the government attacking its
political opponents outside of
government
via the pentagon which again if trump
had done it be considered
authoritarianism
and of course members of our vaunted
media now trying to use
their power to cudgel everybody else
into shutting up pretty incredible stuff
okay meanwhile speaking of cuddling
people into shutting up amazon has now
announced it will not be selling
books will not be selling books framing
lgbtq plus identities as mental
illnesses
i assume that also includes mental
disorders if it includes mental
disorders then they're gonna have to ban
the diagnostic and statistical manual
number five which labels gender
dysphoria
in its actual listing of mental
disorders because it is in fact a mental
disorder
okay now they banned ryan anderson's
book so ryan anderson
of formerly of heritage foundation now
the ethics in public policy center
he had a book called when harry became
sally and the entire book is very well
considered
it does not attempt to say bad things
about people who suffer from gender
dysphoria
it talks about the various medical
solutions that have been proposed and
how effective they are or are not
it's a very well considered well thought
out sympathetic book does not matter
amazon pulled it down
so people tried to get answers from
amazon as to why the book was pulled
down because that is
digital book burning now amazon is
saying according to the wall street
journal
that it recently removed a
three-year-old book about transgender
issues from its platforms because it
decided not to sell books that framed
transgender and other sexual identities
as mental illnesses
the company explained its decision in a
letter thursday to republican senators
marco rubio of florida mikey of utah
mike braun of indiana and josh halley of
missouri
of missouri the senators had written
last month the chief executive jeff
bezos requested
requesting an explanation of why the the
ryan anderson book was pulled down
as to your specific question about when
harry became sally we have chosen not to
sell books that frame lgbtq plus
identity as a mental illness amazon
said in the letter which was signed by
brian huseman amazon's vice president of
public policy referring to sexual
identities that include lesbian gay
bisexual and transgender among others
when harry became sally of course
focuses on a variety of issues including
gender dysphoria anderson
says quote everyone agrees gender
dysphoria is a serious condition that
causes great suffering
okay so what exactly are they banning
and the answer is they're not banning
every book
that says that gender dysphoria is a
mental disorder because it clearly is a
mental disorder it is diagnosed as such
that is why treatment is recommended or
not recommended depending on your point
of view
instead what ryan anderson points out is
there is a debate which amazon is
seeking to shut down
about how best to treat patients who
experience gender dysphoria
they called the book an important
contribution to that conversation they
said amazon is using its massive power
to distort the marketplace of ideas and
it's deceiving its own customers in the
process
okay the the the fact that amazon is now
banning books
on the basis of suggesting for example
that watchful waiting is a better idea
than puberty blockers for children
or the idea that transgender surgery
might not actually be super effective
in fighting the symptoms of gender
dysphoria
that it's banning those books i mean
that's full-fledged
authoritarianism from the corporate
media
and you know that this is amazon's
perspective right i mean this is not
scientifically settled material by any
stretch of the imagination
at all and yet amazon has decided that
the debate is over
so it is only a matter of time before
they start banning books that do not
take the preferred line
on climate change for example if you are
like michael shellenberger or bjorn
lomberg and you suggest that climate
change is occurring but the solutions
provided by the left
are not actually the solutions those
books will be taken down
if you believe that america is not
systemically racist those books
presumably will be taken down
and all you have to do to find out what
amazon is going to take down next and
this is going to happen over the next
couple years during the biden
administration
what you're going to see as amazon
continues to do this all you have to do
to tell what they take down next
is go take a look over at their movie
page because you can see what they are
recommending on the ideological side
so producer savvy sent over an
email from one of our listeners showing
that amazon is currently for women's
history month or for or for independent
women's
day or something international women's
day they were honoring women in film
one of the movies that they're honoring
as female directed for women in film
is the matrix by the waykowski brothers
who are now the wakowski sisters right
they're both transgender women
so amazon is openly making the statement
that the matrix which was directed by
men
okay it was directed by men those those
not only do these people
happen to still be biological men when
they directed the film
they were they even identified as men it
was only later that they started
identifying both as transgender women
now that is considered a female directed
film because again trans
gender politics means that we change not
only the laws of biology
pretending that men are women but also
the laws of physics pretending they were
always women even when they were men
right we actually can
they say time travel is impossible not
anymore now it's completely possible you
can go back and actually change history
by declaring that today
you identify as a woman this means you
are always a woman which means that
bruce jenner is the single greatest
female athlete in human history
sorry caitlyn jenner single greatest
female athlete in human history not even
close
defeating men with ease all the way back
during the olympics in the 70s like
truly incredible stuff
so amazon when they put out when they
decide that they are going to
push the notion that america's
systemically racist you know the next
books that they're going to
punish are going to be books like
heather mcdonald's which claim that
america's police are not systemically
racist
because after all they disagree and this
cannot be allowed to prevail
these views cannot be allowed in the
public sphere
first of all if amazon continues to do
this then we'll just start our own book
service i mean
dw we will we'll start our own book
distribution service
which we can do and we have a tumblr
distribution service we can make a book
distribution service we'll have to do
that
if they continue with this sort of crap
but this is exactly the sort
of woke cram down that is occurring from
everywhere from government to
corporations to now universities
and so this is a crazy story here's a
crazy story from georgetown law
according to the washington post a
georgetown law professor
was terminated and a second was placed
on leave after a video clip showed a
conversation between the pair that
included what an official called
reprehensible statements about black
students officials said thursday
the conversation between adjunct
professors sandra sellers and david
batson had triggered an investigation
by georgetown university's office of
institutional diversity equity and
affirmative action which is an orwellian
title for an office that basically
exists
just to punish people for saying the
wrong things and there's an entire
billion dollar industry in the united
states
offices of diversity and virtually every
company designed to avoid liability
that's really what those are about
you can limit your liability and
exposure to federal lawsuit if you have
an office of diversity that polices
inside your institution quote-unquote
racism even if it's not actually racism
the school's black law students
association had called for sellers as
firing
the video clip shared on twitter this
week showed sellers discussing
student performance sellers said in the
video quote i hate to say this
i end up having this angst every
semester that a lot of my lower ones are
blacks
meaning a lot of my lower performing
students happens almost every semester
and it's like oh come on
you get some really good ones but there
are also usually some that are just
plain at the bottom it drives me crazy
okay now the way this was interpreted is
that black students are inherently
dumber that is not
at all what the professor is obviously
saying the professor is saying
that one of the problems with lowering
standards of admission to have
affirmative action people
to have people get in via affirmative
action means
that you're going to have people who are
misaligned with the school this has been
a
long-supported thesis abigail thurnstrom
wrote about this years ago in the
atlantic when the atlantic was not a
left-wing garbage salon knockoff okay it
used to be
that everybody understood that if you
lower standards for admission a lot of
the people
would have done really well at a school
not as highly ranked as georgetown
actually underperformed schools like
georgetown
because they got in having lower scores
than the rest of the
population at these particular schools
so this professor says some of my best
performing students are black
but a disproportionate number of my
lower performing students are black and
this makes me sad
this makes me upset not sad at the black
students
sad at a system that does not help black
students to the extent that they are
performing better
sad at a system that is deliberately
misaligning a certain number of black
students with the school they should
actually be going to
they'd be succeeding at a school that is
not ranked in the top 20 law schools
they'd be succeeding at school number
40. but at georgetown law they're having
a tough time and this makes the
professor sad this is fireable
if you even note that black students are
disproportionately underperforming
at some of these schools which
statistically they are
this means that you're a racist and if
you're sad about it you're upset about
it you want black students to do better
this means that you're even more of a
racist according to georgetown law
law center dean william traynor said
thursday he informed seller she was
terminated
and that she had indicated she had
planned to resign batson was placed on
administrative leave pending the
investigation trainer said
the dean said the incident underscores
the school's need for more anti-bias
training there it is all you have to do
is pour a few billion more dollars into
the office of diversity
to reindoctrinate everybody into the
idea that you can't have any standards
at all
and then all this will go away by the
way if georgetown law really wants to
fix this problem they should just get
rid of grades
all grades just go away no more grades
not even pass fail
it's impossible to fail everybody it
should be like a baltimore public school
you get past
whether or not you actually know how to
read
he said officials are taking steps to
ensure that students in sellers and
batson's class are graded fairly she
wasn't saying that she was deliberately
grading down black students
precisely the opposite she was saying
that if she could have had the ability
to do so she would have
graded black students better but it's a
problem because they're not performing
as well
sellers shared a resignation with the
washington post in which she apologized
for the hurtful and misdirected remarks
that were part of a longer discussion
about patterns in class participation
i would never do anything to
intentionally hurt my students or
georgetown law and wish i could take
back my words that seller said in the
letter regardless of my intent i've done
irreparable harm and i
am truly sorry for this no you didn't he
didn't do it irreparable harm at all
not one iota of irreparable harm the
only irreparable harm here is that
sellers is never going to work in
academia again
because any school in the future that
hires this particular professor is
immediately going to be hit
with a wave of woke cancellation
they're gonna be hit with a bunch of
students claiming that they are going to
protest at the dean's office if this
professor is hired she just ended her
own academic career by apologizing
she never should have done it she should
have just said that's not what i meant
you all know what i meant
i want black students to do well that
was the entire basis of the conversation
no then she'd be able to work again but
just like everybody who's intimidated
she put her neck out there and they're
going to chop it right off
hassan ahmad a georgetown law student
who posted clips of the remarks on
twitter said the conversation happened
at the conclusion of a negotiations
class
the recording was online for about two
weeks before students noticed the
conversation
the video was reported monday morning
and then taken down soon after
trainer who's the dean said you learned
this week about a conversation between
two faculty members that included
reprehensible student statements
concerning
the evaluation of black students
i'm sorry this is it's just this is
ridiculous it's a deliberate
misinterpretation of what is very
obviously a sympathetic position toward
black students
apparently this is pretty great tiffany
wright
a former supreme court law clerk who
graduated from georgetown law in 2013
they dug
this person up to comment for the
washington post now a practicing
attorney and co-director of the human
and civil rights clinic at howard
university
said she's been dealing with a kind of
micro-aggressions espoused by sellers
since she was a student
she's used to people doubting her
abilities and seeing black people held
to different standards than their white
peers
quote it also has an effect over time on
our mental health you start to absorb
and believe those lies which ones she
said some of her best performing
students are black so which lies are you
believing
the lie that says that some perform well
and some perform badly because that's
true of every racial group
or the truth which is that sometimes
racial groups disproportionately perform
well or badly in particular academic
settings
it's just it's an absurdity but it
doesn't matter it does not matter
by the way the black law students
association also
accused a a professor named carrie
menkel meadow
a professor at marita at georgetown law
and professor at uc irvine of using the
n-word in a class
she denied using the word she said it
was in an article she did assign to
students about regulating hate speech
and the black law students association
tried to have her fired for signing
a for assigning a piece about hate
speech that included the n-word which is
necessary
to explain hate speech and
by the way this whole woke cancel
culture nonsense it's going
international now
apparently a white translator was
removed from an amanda gorman poem
in europe so amanda gorman is this
bizarrely popular
national youth poet laureate can't say
i'm
supremely enamored with her work we'll
also admit i'm not a huge poetry fan so
maybe she's amazing and i just don't
know it
but um i i've never heard a poem of hers
that i didn't think was just prose
divided up so
into into kind of random doggerel in any
case
the uh the there was a a catalan
translator
okay apparently in spain who's been
removed from a job
translating a poem by amanda gorman
because he did not quote fit the profile
the move by the barcelona publisher
universe marks the second instance of
controversy in europe around the choice
of a white person being chosen to
translate the hill we climb by gorman
who is black translator victor obials
told afp
on wednesday universe had commissioned
him last month to translate gorman's
work into catalan
after he completed the job the
publishing house informed him he was not
the right person
he said they told me i am not suitable
to translate it they did not question my
abilities but they were looking for a
different profile which had to be a
woman young activist and preferably
black
so you can't even translate words now
unless you are
a person who who absolutely mirrors the
person who wrote the word
in every respect in fact only amanda
gorman can translate amanda gorman
into catalan all she has to do is learn
catalan and then it'll be no problem
this is the absurdity of our divisive
and polarized culture and it is only
going to get worse from here on in okay
meanwhile
speaking of divisive and polarized
culture i'd be remiss if i did not
comment
on the myers-leonard situation so
myers-leonard
is a forward for the miami heat okay and
myers leonard is very controversial in
the nba because he chose not to kneel
for the national anthem that's why he
first became controversial in the nba
you see
in the nba it is considered good taste
daniel for the national anthem and bad
taste to stand for the national anthem
so he was already controversial
okay so he does all of these kind of
video gaming streams
does myers leonard and while he was
doing one of these video gaming streams
he dropped the k word for jews okay the
k word for jews
is it dates back to i believe germany
i believe is the origin of it it comes
from the the german term for circle
because
jews back in the early 18 the early 19th
century were forced to wear a circle in
public
and so that turned into the the term
that rhymes with mike but starts with k
okay i don't like to say racial slurs on
the program
so so that term was used by myers
leonard
now as a person who's received more
anti-semitic
comments than probably say any american
like literally all the americans
um in 2016 i was named this by the adl
i'm the i have the trophy on my on my
wall
it's fantastic the one that says i was
the most targeted person by
anti-semitism on twitter for all of
2016.
uh so i know what anti-semitism looks
like and i know what it's like to be
targeted by anti-semitism
you don't get the k word a lot except
from kind of alt-writers that's pretty
much the only place that you get the
k-word
meyers leonard is not a member of the
alt-right my guess
is that myers leonard was playing video
games a lot and there were a bunch of
gabbers in there you know eight eight
chan folks
and some of those people were using the
word he didn't know what the word meant
and so he used the word one time i don't
think that he thought oh jew
that means k word and this is what he
said he said you know i didn't know what
the word meant
i thought it was sort of a gamer thing
that people were saying and so i said it
okay that's bad it's an accident it is
certainly less bad
than say lebron james putting out an
instagram post
saying that he was going to get him some
jewish money
he literally put out an instagram post
just a couple of years back that said
we've been getting that jewish money
everything is kosher
there's a picture of himself tweeting
those lyrics to 45 million people
okay now here's the thing both of these
things are not great
right one of them is explicitly
anti-semitic in terms of you know the
jewish money thing
the other one is pretty obviously coming
from a place of of tremendous ignorance
myers-leonard apologized lebron james
apologized
myers leonard was with a 50 000 fine the
maximum allowed by league policy and
suspended from using all miami heat
facilities and activities for one week
in response to his use of the term
adam silver said that he believes
leonard is genuinely remorseful he said
myers leonard's comment
was inexcusable hurtful such an
offensive term has no place in the nba
or in our society he's going to be
required to participate in a cultural
diversity program
silver said we have further communicated
to myers that derogatory comments like
this will not be tolerated and who will
be expected to uphold the core values of
our league equality tolerance inclusion
and respect
at all times moving forward so that was
the maximum fine that could be issued by
adam silver for anything
it's unclear how this will affect
understanding with the miami heat
the miami heat said the lender would be
away from the team indefinitely
okay they said that they are going to
continue to communicate with myers as he
educates himself in all of this okay so
that's what happened to myers leonard
what happened to lebron james
after lebron james instagram's out we've
been getting that jewish money
everything is kosher
what happened to him nothing of course
nothing happened to lebron james
or what happened to um dwyane wade
another person
who has been a star for the miami heat
when for example
dwyane wade defended nick cannon you
remember that nick cannon was fired
because he went on this wild
anti-semitic diatribe
in the middle of a podcast dwayne wade
came out
and tweeted we are with you with an
emoji of a black fist
keep leading he tweeted to nick cannon
was dwyane wade hit with um you know any
uh any fine by the nba
and even who was retired by that point
he's still associated with with the
league he's still associated with
i believe one of the teams i think the
heat so was there anything that happened
to uh dwyane wade
how about you know actually other active
players like for example
it turns out that that other players
including kevin durant expressed
sympathy for desean jackson desean
jackson had issued a wild anti-semitic
statement
he had suggested that jewish people own
all the banks and
he had uh he had put up anti-semitic
content on instagram including a quote
misattributed to adolf hitler
he was defended by former nba player
stephen jackson and then
j.r smith and kevin durant both liked
steven jackson's posts on instagram
did either jr smith or kevin durant get
fined by the nba
so here's what we have here we have
anti-semitism coming from lebron james
dwyane wade j.r smith and kevin durant
and then
an anti-semitic slur used presumably
accidentally by myers leonard
myers leonard who is white gets fined
fifty thousand dollars and suspended for
a week and indefinitely by the heat
nothing for lebron nothing for kd
nothing for j.r smith nothing for dwyane
wade
weird very very strange so do i think
that the nba
cares about bigotry or do i think that
the nba is wildly biased in how it
applies its standards of justice
yes i'm talking about the same nba that
thought that it was completely fine for
lebron james to undercut
the hong kong freedom movement because
they're making money in china but
continue to suggest that black men are
under existential threat in a country
where lebron james is one of the most
powerful
cultural figures in america earning
literally 100 million a year
probably i mean like yes it turns out
that the nba has a bit of an agenda here
and that agenda
has something to do with race and that
agenda has something to do with politics
and has
very very little to do with principle
none of that's an excuse for myers
leonard but myers leonard
if he's going to be fined then certainly
all these other players should have been
fined
and by the way i happen to believe that
myers leonard did that by accident i do
not think that it was by accident when
you defend nick cannon saying openly
anti-semitic things
or when you put up posts that say
getting that jewish money
to the applause apparently and
non-punishment of the nba already we'll
be back here later today with an
additional hour of content
first you cannot forget to end your week
by checking out the andrew clavin show
drew's shows every friday he's got an
exciting night planned for you so head
on over to dailywire.com this evening at
7 pm eastern
and tune in i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
bourne
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wydowski
editing is by adam sciovitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin